after missing three in a row  seven point game  ubra  from three rebounded by randall see  mostly would not even shoot the ball  there  right why not take some time off the  clock yeah  i showed you how team squander leaves  lubricate previously was the culprit  with the ilive  turnover and now shooting this ball from  the corner  you can see michael's saying the same  thing why would you shoot that ball  run the clockman  down to 29 and four tenths  seconds remaining  [Music]  stay tuned after the game for a complete  recap of  tonight's action on the tri-state audi  knicks  post-game show  with bill allen and wally  yeah a little deja vu for those guys  who saw a similar scenario that we saw  in new york  where the second unit got the team back  even got the lead but couldn't hold on  will take a look  at the last play